mich beschäftigt coruna in bezug auf die
demokratie spaltet das die gesellschaft
und bedroht das eigentlich nicht auf
unsere demokratie denn wir merken dass
der umgang mit der pandemie immer mehr
uns spaltet und was ich eigentlich sagen
will ist dass 2015 schon mit der
flüchtlingsfrage eine große spaltung
hatten jetzt mit der pandemie und die
frage ist eigentlich was soll noch
kommen
das problem ist der riss geht durch die
familien da geht durch belegschaften der
geht durch freundeskreise durch mann war
schon gar nicht mit einfach quer durch
die gesellschaft und die frage ist wie
können wir diesen riss eigentlich
überhaupt noch wieder heil wie können
wir ihnen schließen und meine meinung
ist wir können nur noch durch
demokratische teilhabe schließen und das
heißt erstens wir brauchen gelöste
bürger räte wo alle positionen in der
gesellschaft leben an einen tisch kommen
miteinander diskutieren und vorschläge
für die politik erarbeitet zweitens
brauchen wir eigentlich abstimmungen im
land also volksabstimmung um in
grundsätzlichen fragen auch gibt
menschen entscheiden zu lassen wenn sie
das möchten das ist eine these
ja das ist eine these die auf einer
diagnose beruht die diagnose teile ich
zunächst mal und befinde mich damit im
gegensatz unserem bundeskanzler olaf
scholz spd der sagt nämlich wir haben
gar keine spaltung kommt drauf an wie
man das gesagt er hat sie jetzt noch mal
gesagt in seiner regierungserklärung
also gestern war das nach dem motto ist
in jahr zwei drittel geimpft also sind
wir gar nicht gespalten und es sind nur
einige andere die stress machen das
finde ich einfach sehr unterkomplex weil
alle problemlösungen beginnt damit
realität anzuschauen und sie haben
völlig recht ihre diagnose die
gesellschaft ist gespalten und nicht
alle die sich jetzt nicht mitgenommen
fühlen wie es so schön heißt oder die
etwa im skeptiker sind was ja nicht
verboten ist sind nicht alle
durchgedreht oder extremisten ich finde
den vorschlag mit den mit den gelösten
bürger räten und den zunehmenden
volksabstimmung erst mal sehr sehr
charmant weil durch das los auf eine
gewisse zufälligkeit hinein kommt man
ist dann frei von interessensvertretern
man 17 weil man gelost worden ist und
ich war mal in einer branche group
vertritt also das wäre also auch ein
mittel gegen diesen unglaublichen buß
der identitätspolitik das finde ich sehr
gut wir müssen allerdings zunächst mal
sagen natürlich nicht corona gefährde
die demokratie sondern der umgang der
politik mit
grund dafür ist einfach sehr sehr
schlecht und riskant wenn also immer
weiter der keil die gesellschaft
getrieben wird mit dem rhein argument
die mehrzahl macht ja mit welcher etwa
herrn söder höre ich kann halt nicht
spanier haben der dann sagt lassen sich
noch impfen und dann heißen wir sie
wieder willkommen in der gemeinschaft
das heißt also man ist nicht mehr von
sich eine gemeinschaft und gesellschaft
man muss etwas leisten man muss durch
eine aktive impfung zeigen dass man zu
den guten gehört man sollte für das
impfen werben mann soll argumentieren
das völlig richtig aber man soll die die
anderer meinung jetzt noch sind oder auf
leicht zu bleiben nicht diffamieren so
würde ich sagen das ist erstmal eine
bringschuld unsere politik alexander für
mich war der höhepunkt weil du markus
söder als als markus so das bild von
sich gepolstert mit der maske draußen im
schnee niemand um ihn rum dadurch zog es
hat die politik völlig den verstand
verloren doch so was raus zu geben ich
finde ich übrigens auch das spaltet das
macht ja auch an warum trinkt er jetzt
schon im schnee das ist ja die leute die
frage sei
also weil da jemand gegenüber stand das
bild auch gemacht hat
sie haben glaube ich gerade auch
möglicherweise bei entsprechenden
publikationen ihres hauses wurden ja
schon oft auch die politik gezeigt wo
dann keine maske da war mal gesagt hat
wissen das jetzt für ein vorbild also
ich glaube deswegen das kann man jetzt
nicht
richtig und gut es war die richtige wahl
sie sagen auch
völlig ist doch völlig zweifelsfrei das
maske tragen
das ist die maske zu tragen ein
entscheidender schritt in der pandemie
bekämpfung ist ganz klar und deswegen
ist es wichtig dass auch zu zeigen
es ist das hat jetzt
das schadet also das
eigentliche problem ist doch tatsächlich
die ausgrenzung der andersdenkenden dass
gerade die diffamierende und wir fangen
an dich nur die meinung zu verachten von
andersdenkenden sondern wir verachten
gleich den ganzen menschen aber wir sind
hier an der stelle wird das fängt bei
uns allen an die frage ist wie viel
anders denkt wir haben wir dann noch mal
im eigenen freundeskreis noch und
begehen wenn mit den unglaublich stelle
fest und das ist tatsächlich
besorgniserregend dass immer mehr
menschen stumm werden und die demokratie
an sich an zweifel die sind im umgang
mit der pandemie an existenzielle nöte
geraten und fangen an die demokratie zu
hinterfragen bisher ist es so gewesen
dass polarisierung immer möglich war
weil wir uns im rahmen des
demokratischen raums befanden aber ich
würde jetzt das erste mal merke ich dass
der demokratische raum selber mit
eingezogen wird und das ist absolut
problematisch und wir müssen momentan
und dessen bewusst sein ob wir noch mehr
in die kerbe reingehen und diese rede
von herrn scholz war wirklich also so
ignorant kann man gar nicht sein dass
man einfach wirklich andersdenkende
ausgrenzt und man muss nicht ihrer
meinung sein aber man muss sie hören und
ich erwarte von der politik auch einfach
mal nachzufragen und hinzuhören und zu
sagen das ist nicht eine große mischpoke
wie die alle in einen topf geschmissen
wird also nämlich interessiert ihre
meinung ihre meinung ihre meinung und
die vielfalt der meinung die ergibt
tatsächlich einen gesamtblick und aus
dem heraus sollten dann entwickelt
deswegen sag es mal ganz frisch also die
auch ich finde das charmant und wie
gesagt ich habe ja auch schon gerne an
an ihrem prozess der bürger räte und
diesen dingen beteiligt auch schon
früher einführen beteiligungsprozesse
aber jetzt mal in der praxis also ich
glaube ja wir sind total diese
gesellschaft ist total gestresst ich
glaube nicht dass sie von haus aus
gestalten ist sondern sie ist total
gestellt leistet was würde denn jetzt
passieren wenn wir was sie ja auch
gefordert haben sagen wir machen jetzt
eine volksabstimmung zum thema und das
wäre ja das thema tatsächlich was auf
uns zukommt nämlich zum thema impfzwang
ja nein das würde zu einer totalen
polarisierung sorgen denn wir würden
hätten einen wahlkampf von
verschiedensten gruppen nicht nur den
parteien und den politischen akteuren
sondern sozusagen von verschiedensten
gruppen wo das zur zentralen frage
gestellt
würde
würde die polarisierung noch viel
sagen ich
glaube dafür bin ich natürlich ein stück
weit gewählt dass ich mir das natürlich
sozusagen tag und nacht
beschäftigen und vielleicht sozusagen
die dinge anders an ich glaube das ist
genau das was viele bürger stört weil
sie spüren dass die politik sich über
sie stellt und sagt ich bin eigentlich
gewählt um dich zu schützen
so leben wir in einem freien land und
auf ihr beispiel zurückzukommen wir
könnten jetzt ganz pragmatisch eine
bürgerrat einberufen der zum beispiel
die entscheidung der bundestag berät
impfpflicht allgemeine impfpflicht ja
oder nein oder eingeschränkt oder wie
auch immer befristet sowieso und so
weiter so und dann könnte man und das
wäre jetzt vorbild schweiz sowas haben
wir ein fakultatives referendum oder wir
sagen volks einwand dann würde nämlich
das gesetz beschlossen im bundestag und
müsste 100 tage warten und innerhalb
dieser 100 tage hätte die bevölkerung
die möglichkeit mit einer bestimmten
unterschriftenzahl ein volksentscheid
über diese abstimmung herbeizuführen der
schweiz jahren ist das wunderbare
ganz kurz nach und das pandemie
eingesetzt wurde diesem juni ergänzt in
der schweiz über ein referendum und
jetzt im november noch einmal ausgebaut
und das zertifikat mit 3g verabschiedet
und dazu noch eine abstimmung dass die
ganze pflege situation verbessert wird
also wir können an der stelle
tatsächlich nur lernen und auch mehr
vertrauen haben in unseren wirklich ganz
christoph schuler sein und wahllos
werden
ich mag auch ihre leidenschaft aber
wir haben sicher weise nicht die
volksabstimmung tradition wie sie in der
schweiz
vorherrscht und ich halte das für schwer
es für schwer kombinierbar also wenn ich
jemanden wähle und entsenden damit er
entscheidet weil er mein weil er mich
glücklicherweise eine mehrheit habe und
meine partei wird am ende
mehrheitsführer und entscheidet etwas
und dann kommt dem bürgerrat grätschte
rein und revidiert dass neben warum habe
warum habe ich eine empfehlung also und
der volksentscheid so wie wir in den
ländern haben wir haben wir ihn schon
380 der
exit ist das beispiel wie man es nicht
macht was war von oben initiiert in drei
monaten konzentrierter unfairer
diskussions kaufen sie kennt auch selber
sie haben die besten erfahrungen in
bayern auf landesebene haben wir die
dreistufige volksgesetzgebung jeder
franken bereit auch das
aussprechen genau und es auch man
kompromissmöglichkeiten und es gibt auch
wir wollen keine regelungen wie ein
projekt wie beim drechseln wir wollen
die regelung wie sie in den ländern ist
und dass eben auch auf das volk hat
falsch abgestimmt in großbritannien
dafür ziehen wir bremsen
entdeckt ist es sinnlos prozess war
nicht fährt zusammen solche wesentliche
solange wir haben doch eine regelung
dass man hier in deutschland
mehrere entscheidungen in deutschland
sind kein ausweis von erfolg entweder
sind die quoren so gering dass der
volksentscheid überhaupt gültig ist wenn
die poren zu hoch sind gehen in der
regel viel zu wenig leute hin und dann
kann man das ganze vergessen oder aber
die quoten sind sehr gering dann haben
wir das kleine demokratische problem
dass eine winzige mehrheit von sammer
zehn prozent der friedrichshain darüber
entscheidet ob der der osthafen gebaut
wird oder nicht weil die anderen sind
nicht hingegangen unseren reichen zehn
prozent von den hängen einwohner sache
entscheide dann in grundsätzlichen fang
ich sag ihnen bei solchen fragen wie der
allgemeine impfpflicht da wäre die
bevölkerung auf der zinne nicht nur in
der schweiz beteiligen sich 62 würde im
moment über das center für geschäftigen
sage ich bei grundsätzlichen wesen
lassen damit sie gar nicht erst mal
anfangen man muss aber grundsätzlich
festlegen ob man die teilnehmer quoren
beispielsweise unterschriftensammlung
niedrig hält wie in der innerschweiz
beispielsweise 100.000 200.000 das wäre
bei dem 80 millionen volk nicht wirklich
demokratisch oder man setzt sie hoch und
sagt jetzt zehn millionen unterschriften
und du hast ein volksentscheid aber wenn
wir das nicht zusammen dann gehst du
nach hause doch bei allem das bringt
nicht sind doch alle probleme die wir
jetzt haben haben wir aufgrund oder auch
durch die verfahren die momentan an
wänden und die gesellschaft ist momentan
sehr gestresst sie ist müde ich würde
sagen wir leben eine angst gesellschaft
und das gericht schon dafür dass man
auch mal gedanken machen über andere
formen der partizipation
ich möchte nicht haben dass wir alle
vier jahren in eine pandemie kommt und
da wird noch mehr gespalten die
gesellschaft und holtmann als blaupause
die vielleicht gescheiterte kubik
politik hervor und sagt jetzt greifen
wir nochmal richtig durch also ich finde
wir sind an so einem schlechten
gesellschaften zustand und ahnt dass wir
uns zumindest diese frage ja nicht
verkneifen sollte aber wir hatten
zumindest mindestens also wir hatten in
dieser pandemie ja auch eine
bundestagswahl das tenor und insofern
hatten auch hier die wählerinnen und
wähler und das war vielleicht auch grund
für die extrem hohe wahlbeteiligung
die chance natürlich auch über über
politiken zu entscheiden und
wenn man
jetzt sehen sozusagen wer wie gegen
pflicht jetzt alle für die impfpflicht
die politik also wo konnten
die fdp fragen das ob das der preis war
die ampel hin zu bekommen oder nicht